Ronni mostly is curving up Los Angeles I
heard you already first thing I heard
about you was you were complaining to
someone that fame is becoming too much
for you no I didn't say that I said I go
places and I get recognizing people yeah
like I was in a restaurant Friday night
in Long Island right and having dinner
and like with what happens to you people
coming over to the table yeah
take the winner what they want to take a
picture in the middle of dinner you know
see yeah but I do it you do it I
understand it but but he said it's
getting to be too much I did say it was
getting to be too much I just said it's
it happens more often by the way let me
say good morning to the Ronny puppet who
is got a new outfit for LA you got
sunglasses yeah and what is your shirt
let me see it's my salamander tattoo
yeah all the chicks love it yeah all the
kinds of salivate but I what I heard a
lot of things
blown out no no well I heard you
complaining about your fame it's getting
to be too much I want the fans to
[ __ ] stay away from that was it was
kind of that Jason what did you do you
want me to autograph their [ __ ]
didn't you hear things absolutely he
complained because his fame is getting
too much I can't handle it I can't get a
free second to myself oh my he could say
whatever he wants I didn't say that I
can't go anywhere without the fans
bother recognize Mike I might say that
Ronnie is Fame too much seriously is it
hard to handle how you negotiating all
of your fame honestly in other words you
can't go anywhere without the fans
hounding you right security do you need
security no but is it really getting too
much like a you crave on your privacy
that's cool do you remember a time I
came with the people do you remember a
time when you weren't famous was it
preferable did you enjoy it more being
not faint now I'm being able to walk I
meet you I enjoy it you enjoy your face
being honest with me because the general
impression everyone's getting is that
you're having a hard time to go shooting
your face I'm breaking balls like they
do I see you he is the head that wears
the [ __ ] crown we don't have to worry
about you alright Jason as long as
you're here yeah tell everyone what the
big news was that Ronnie's been up to
since Ronnie mister sex has been sexting
with his fiance back homes and I gotta
hand it to you Ronnie amazing at your
age you're sexting while you're here
with your fiance I was in my room fat
you know just laying and watching TV I
was holding my [ __ ] my god it was nine
o'clock at night I was laying in bed so
I took a picture my [ __ ] say cheese
balls were you excited oh okay oh you
worked yourself shot a picture and then
I just sent the time she didn't know I
was sending it she had no clue Kurt
you're on the air
hey Ronnie I just wanted an autograph of
a picture your bathroom since you're
famous now it's getting harder and
harder to get a Ronnie autograph
I'll be signing pictures with my dick